معركه طوباخموت الاكثر دمويه والاطول في
الحرب الاوكرانيه فجرت خلافا في اوساط
القياده باكياف وفق تقارير المانيه وفي
التفاصيل نقلت صحيفه بيلد الالمانيه
المعروفه بقربها من دوائر صنع القرار في
كييف عن مصادر لم تسميها ان خلافا انزلع
بين الرئيس الاوكراني
واهم جنرالاته وهو فاليري حول معركه باخمد
بالذات والخلاف بين الرجلين اعتبرته
الصحيفه ربما يكون طموحا سياسيا على ان
يكون مرشحا جديا لرئاسه البلاد ذا لجنه لم
يكشف ابدا عن نيته القفز للامام في هرم
السلطه باوكرانيا لكن يبدو ان زيلينسكي
والبيئه المحيطه به يرونه منافسا محتملا
وفق طبعا الصحيفه الالمانيه اما الاوساط
العسكريه الاوكرانيه فاعتبرت ان القائد
العام للقوات المسلحه يعمل فقط من اجل
النصر على القوات الروسيه ويحاول حمايه
جنوده بافضل طريقه ممكنه وهذا هو الذي ادى
للمناقشات مع القياده السياسيه حول
[موسيقى]